I'm starting to see it here in America
where that the Asian Community is not
being treated as one of the ethnic
minorities and they are being treated as
quasi-conservative Yale University had a
big lawsuit about how they were
discriminating heavily against Asian
students so that they could have more
numbers of other minorities that would
come in and get federal grants so they
were bringing minorities admitting them
into Yale and after Biden won the
election this is the federal government
dropped the Sioux and so I'm hearing a
lot about that what are you seeing
obviously you saw it firsthand with the
FBI are you seeing this in other areas
where you know you know Asians coming to
this country are being treated as well
you know it's harder to turn you into a
lifelong Democrat you're more likely to
be conservative and so we're taking
steps have you seen that since you've
been here yeah I think I heard that very
often I talk about right did I talk
about the cancer culture and the danger
of it and talk about the oppression that
real oppression is happening in China
and North Korea or Iran and they say
that like how do you know about
oppression because you are a white
passing person
wow yeah so it's interesting like they
view now Asians as white because we are
also making a lot of money I think who
is saying this to you this I mean like
college students
they listen as a white guy
I don't think that Asians I've never
been like look at those Asians over
there oh those white people they they're
privileged it's just it so this isn't
adding up to me we'll talk about the
admissions group but let me just go to
the story that validates what she's
saying I I think I understand what
you're saying fully that physically
you're like yeah you're not you're not a
white guy white lady categorically they
think there is such thing as Asian
privilege the the privileged part that
they see white privilege and Asian
privilege that being a real thing let me
just read the story yeah so most
Americans think college admissions
should not consider race okay 62 of
Americans are say race and ethnicity
should not be considered at all in
college admissions according to a new
Reuters poll okay the public opinion
found uh that 73 of Republicans and 46
percent of Democrats said they were
against race conscious admissions or
affirmative action which is a practice
used by colleges and universities to
boost racial diversity with within their
student bodies again 73 percent of
Republicans say no I don't want to know
about the race I just want to know who's
the best students but 46 percent of
Democrats say meaning 54 saying no we
have to consider what race it is before
you get into college grades don't matter
your race does right that's what they're
saying 67 percent of white respondents
said they were against considering race
at all in admissions compared to 52
percent of minority respondents the
conservative leading U.S Supreme Court
will issue ruling this spring in cases
questioning the legality of race
conscious admissions practices at
Harvard and University of North Carolina
the group behind the lawsuit student of
uh for Fair admission says that UNC
discriminations discriminates against
white and Asian American applicants and
Harvard discriminates against Asian
American applicants that was the
question Tom was asking do you think we
should consider race when it comes down
to going to universities I think that's
what I'm like I was writing in my book
that's like the tactics they
divide people
punish people
like they're saying like oh Adam is
white therefore his ancestors were
privileged people and now he should be
guilty right
I think that tactic is like a very North
Korean tactic like my great grandfather
was a landowner so they were saying when
I was born my genetics is oppressive my
blood is Tainted therefore I can never
be forgiven even though that was not my
choice to on the land
Now in America we punished like I have a
son who's a half white he's so screwed
he's supposed to be guilty about a
privilege they have white and Asian yeah
I mean he's double guilty teleporting to
uh according to these guys yeah and
actually based on the just merits the
competence it says just Asians should be
at Harvard more than 70 percent of them
should be Asians if you're gonna let
them in buy the Merit and exam score but
then Harvard only accepts 11 point
something percent each year because they
have like the quora race quora
so actually the real victims of
affirmative action is like Asians yeah
they say so hard and that's how they get
punished for it
so I think this is one of the things
that I see we become like North Korea we
do not value the marriage and competence
and somehow accepting dividing People
based on what they are not responsible
for which is a collective gift
I think you you you hit the the nail on
the head there is that more than
anything in America not only we are
democracy but we are a meritocracy you
talked about Merit why are Asians
overwhelmingly being uh considered or
admitted to Harvard is because they
[__] kick ass in school how about
that like if you look at certain
ethnicities okay I'm Jewish if you look
at income in America you could fact
check this I don't know I want to say
Asians and Jews are leading the list
yeah okay also Indians to a certain
extent as well and why is that because
they come from a culture that that
values hard work education and there's a
culture and the tight-knit family family
values and being raised in a two-parent
household and there's a multitude of
reasons why these types of people
succeed now uh from what I know about my
Jewish mother they do they're a lot more
like kissy Huggy Huggy than a lot of my
Asian friends I've had conversations
with my Asian friends they're they're
more bowing and all that but the family
values and the the close-knit value and
the emphasis on education is tantamount
to these types of families and no wonder
there's going to be success like like
the tiger mom uh you know story about
all that is like they demand that you do
your work like is anyone going to be
shocked that Pat's kids are going to be
are going to do well and successful why
because it's a meritocracy even in his
house did you read did you shoot your
shots did you just play outside today
did you do all your work if you did that
then you can go play video games and
have fun with your friends but there's
accountability there and that's exactly
what's going on in Asian households and
a lot of times in Jewish households and
you know for other people in America
that don't have that type of
accountability
one day you guys watch it the pressure
isn't on you one of you guys is gonna do
something big we'll see which one
good job anyways let's go over here all
right so uh uh uh going back so question
basic question and run a poll for this
Rob so we can see what the audience is
saying should it's a very basic question
yes or no all of us should American
colleges
consider race when accepting
applications Adam
uh I think
race should not be on a top ten list
okay Vinnie no I I 100 say no Tom no no
okay now of course it's going to be no
for mine you know to to and by the way
here's what's crazy I should say yes do
you know why because if my kids are
playing they say they're from Iran it's
like hey we need to hit our numbers for
Iran yeah yeah look at these guys in
yeah Jack and pick and choose one if I
can say Armenian I can say Syrian listen
there's only two of us in America
future minimums you know but Emma
percent right huh you get the Emma
percent Europe Middle East Africa we
need some of that check listen look at
who who is the current up-and-coming
superstar in the NBA that's 23 years old
okay how high does he jump
he's just a big guy but he's a great
player yes and nobody should care what
skin color he is he just kicks out he's
not even from America by the way he's
from uh you know you're where's he from
Slovenia Slovenia right on what he does
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]